[Music]
[Applause]
i know what you're thinking greg's never
looked this good in a dress and he's
even shorter than normal even with six
inch heels and he's smiling
surprise it's me emily
[Applause]
like a tiny ghost of christmas present
because i'm celebrating the holiday
today
because this year kovid robbed me of
christmas with my family
coveted robbed us of our studio audience
and it robbed me of my christmas eve
feast of the seven fishes the italian
tradition of eating seafood and yelling
so to make up for it we are having a
feast tonight not actual food jimmy
don't get excited
it's emily's feast of seven jokes
emily's feast of seven jokes
in new year's eve news omicron fear
mongers are warning people to stay away
from new york's times square celebration
even though previous crowds were exposed
to something much worse anderson cooper
and kathy griffin
thank god it'll be me hosting in times
square this year see you at 10 pm
eastern on fox news
germany's also banned large group
gatherings but you know who's never
banned large gatherings of germans
france
china's wuhan institute of virology
recently hosted a conference on lab
safety to which the world responded a
little
late guys
[Laughter]
in a recent segment on covid safety
cnn's dr lena wen admitted cloth masks
don't stop transmission of the virus
they also don't stop cnn hosts from
grabbing your ass
today new york mayor bill de blasio said
he doesn't believe in shutdowns despite
having shut down the city for months
he then added quote i also oppose
letting criminals roam free to murder
people
[Laughter]
chris tucker turned down a 10 million
dollar payday for a sequel to the
awesome movie friday saying he's too
mature to be seen behaving badly on
screen anymore but producer ice cube has
found a replacement who has no qualms
about cursing or smoking weed on camera
[Music]
in a cbs news interview vice president
kamala harris said her biggest failure
was not getting out of dc more but for
once i actually agree with kamala i'd
love to see her get out of dc
permanently
thank you all this has been emily's
feast of seven jokes
so by this point you may be wondering
how the little sister got the keys to
the car
is this like in the goonies where the
kids let the air out of bran's bike tire
so they get a head start no greg prefers
a tricycle
is greg tied up naked with duct tape
over his mouth dumped in the girl's
locker room wait no that was him in high
school
is he draped over the side of
killmeade's hot tub naked three bottles
of wine deep wait no that was him on
christmas
no i'm actually sitting here for one
reason
i beat him in a good old-fashioned card
game
you want to play poker against me
strip poker
not that kind of game we don't work for
andrew cuomo
this card game
exactly the kind greg loves it combines
two of his favorite passions
and i never turn down an invitation
especially
not with the high stakes of the keys to
the kingdom for one night because the
one thing no one bets on is the little
sister having the best poker face and
outlasting them all
emily good to see your
got your real estate license you're like
a hot topic uh real estate sake agent
anyway i'll take it out you're a goth
you sell gothic houses here's emily from
25 years ago
oh wow
you've changed but i totally support the
transition and the decision i am the
number one late-night host emily i'm not
some
i'm not somebody you could push around
you make me sick and for that you have
to sit out this segment
straight to bed straight to bed like you
always do
up at the crack of dawn yep good for you
psychopath
oh i sat there and took it but just like
andy dufresne veronica the frog brothers
ronald miller the monster squad and
kylie richards in her oft overlooked
role as ellie curtis and watcher in the
woods the underdogs always come out on
top except in rocky one
that's why i'm here tonight as a living
breathing message of hope like a tiny
ghost of christmas future
not just for this hour but for the long
haul
in the immortal words of yoko's
boyfriend it will all be okay in the end
if it's not okay it's not the end
2021 has sucked no doubt look who's in
the white house look who's not in the
white house
half of us are in lockdowns under
mandates bill cosby is free and yet paul
weyland is still imprisoned
china is experimenting with hypersonic
missiles and our military is
experimenting with diversity training
the only thing that grew bigger than our
federal government this year was the
criminal liability of cnn producers
the world is mourning the loss of
captain von trapp raider nations john
madden screech clary and joe devito's
favorite movie steel magnolias and rosen
moonstruck and the genius mind behind
lestat the mainstream media encouraged
by feckless elected officials played an
attention shell game where kovid played
on loop while urban implosions the
southern border record surge
skyrocketing homicides disconnected
public schools opioid overdoses a social
war waged on law enforcement and
americans left behind in afghanistan
barely received any coverage
the media did keep us well informed
however on who would host jeopardy
there were other stories too stories
that deserved our attention our
admiration our disgust but where was the
media msnbc was busy chasing down jury
buses sure but what's everyone else's
excuse
where was the coverage when an escaped
prisoner on the lam was finally caught
after venturing out to buy call of duty
where were the headlines when teens
dumping a murdered body in the woods
were caught because they dutifully left
their hazard lights on
where were the media alerts when six
colossal dumbasses kidnapped and held
for ransom a victim just steps away from
an nypd training facility you can
imagine how that turned out
but in the interest of fairness i have
to hold the mirror up to this show as
well i borrowed one of the 10 in joey's
office
it's true even greg missed a huge story
this year likely the largest story of
the year which is shocking honestly
because we heard it from the source
himself from channing tatum
yes
great news for america greg and me there
will be a magic mic 3.
not sure why this hasn't headlined every
episode of gut fell since but earlier
this month it was confirmed two of the
greatest movies of all time will now be
part of a trilogy of human perfection so
take heart america
2022 will be better than 2021 or at the
very least it'll have better abs
yeah
despite all our differences the one
thing greg and i have in common the one
love we share is magic mike
watching and performing
so in our shared great anticipation of
the release of magic mike 3 next year i
put together what i knew greg would love
a gut-felled rendition of the most
engorging or engrossing
the most delightful performance not on
broadway
i give you
gigantic greg
[Music]
but what if brian still to lose his
weight all right guys it's time for our
rehearsal for gigantic greg great news i
invited channing tatum to come
i know
bad news the restraining order is still
in effect and so i'm not allowed within
50 feet of them
but you know what we don't need him we
have all the talent we need right here
[Music]
ready dancer number one
[Music]
love the method acting but let's ramp up
the energy
[Music]
g'day guys how we feeling tonight i'm
bringing the thunder from down under
great rhythm gene
are unicorns australian
[Music]
can you do something funny joe you're a
clown
but i'm so much more than that
[Music]
good try
let's try not scaring the audience
[Music]
okay great job by the way
whoa
great use of space this isn't a duet
where i'm from this is how we say hello
last time gigantic red let's do this and
five six seven eight and one two three
four five
oh
maybe we need a different show in common
with less dancing
sex in the city yes i got miranda oh
shotgun charlotte
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests fox
news's own magic mike our bionic half
robot half aquaman johnny joey jones
fox news's tragic mike comedian and host
of fox across america jimmy fayla
fox news's hemorrhagic mike gushing out
joke comedian joe devito
and mike's hot sister fox news
contributor cat tim
[Applause]
all right jimmy we just covered a lot of
ground a lot went on
this was a lot to hit a guy with who
looks like a d a mall santa who got a
dui
who really came to me otherwise known as
amal santa
every single one
it's so amazing right now you get like
five duis because the kova they're out
of santa's they just keep bringing me
back
i just gotta bring me back in keep the
kids far away um i didn't know that you
guys are obsessed with magic mike but i
love the idea of magic mike because it
is the cinematic equivalent of being
single so long you buy a cat you know
they should give every woman who buys a
ticket the magic mic a free scoop of
litter with their purchase what it is
it's a horny cat lady movie
the movie took in 167 million dollars
last time around but it took forever to
count because they paid in singles
the last flight i was on there was
literally a whole row of us and we were
all watching it and everyone loved it
but i love what i learned about
my rumor worked and so now everyone
literally thinks greg is obsessed with
metal
i just love that everyone loved it who
are you flying with the golden girl
that was there
joey that skit is what i envision the
marine corps barracks look like after
hours is that true yeah we pretty much
get naked and look at each other
and i'll tell you i'm a big chafing
scrotum fan
i like his work
i've never seen magic mike though i've
seen where he played a marine there's
literally some movies called the marine
and it's like the marine again and he
does a good job but is magic mike about
dudes taking her clothes off is that
what i'm figuring out here
loosely
taking their loose clothes
a bunch of stripper boys or just one i
never saw it it depends on who is in the
spotlight in your eyes it's really about
a bunch of them but there's only i mean
let's face it there's one there's one
magic mic
joe davina do you think greg is missing
us right now should we call him gigantic
greg actually from now on i will not be
i think um right now greg is in a ditch
inside cat's baby
putting the lotion in the basket
by the way were you trapped in a
blockbuster video for about a decade
your movie references seemed to be very
much you saved it with rocky i was i was
lost
in rocky i'm like yeah devito wrote that
line everything else with me
so cat what do you think about the
stories that the media missed there were
really important ones my wedding there
you go
and the honeymoon is going to be an even
bigger story because it's taken so long
to have one i know but i keep saying
we're gonna it's
how it's never ends we're gonna end up
having to go go to poughkeepsie
for two weeks i've never been at school
either it's actually lovely this they'll
probably treat me great i would be the
queen of poughkeepsie
i'll see you guys there uh yeah a lot of
stuff there um you know what i don't
know how people keep missing that it's
not okay
if it's not the end it'll be i don't get
that
because the end is the worst part you
die no the end is the best part it's
like when they kiss or when they walk
down the aisle or when like the bank is
robbed or you know it's something it's
something awesome right no i don't know
of anything that ends with just a kiss i
mean we're all adults right
are we are we are we in seventh grade uh
well listen well on the hallmark channel
and on this channel we just entered i
was gonna say yeah this time of year it
ends they kiss it snows they play some
terrible christmas music and then the
exact same movie with the exact same gay
actors kissing women comes on again
every hallmark channel
and they all get five stars you know
that like eighty percent of the homework
channels ratings are guys just ragging
on the movies while their women watch
them who are you roger
loves the movie
[Laughter]
which tells me cam will be going to see
me i said if you don't turn this off i'm
gonna go back to my hometown and meet a
guy who owns a bookstore
exactly all right joey final question
yeah again is a marine
when you hear that someone ventured out
of being on the lamb to buy call of duty
and that's what got him caught does it
make you shake your head well you don't
have a 12 year old son who really likes
video games so i don't know like if it
were him
i might be kind of proud you know like
you get it when you took the initiative
but for a grown for a grown man you know
it's probably not the thing to do you
know i'm not a big video game guy i
owned a playstation one time and i
traded it for speakers for my truck and
i traded those i think for it doesn't
matter what i traded those for actually
so i don't get the video games the call
of duty stuff i don't understand it i
kind of did call of duty one time
exactly hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else